معنا الان من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي يرحب بك سيد
ايهاب وايانا نبدا باخر خبر اذا وهذا
الاتصال المطول كما وصفه بايدن مع نتنياهو
وتاكيد من قبل نتنياهو بان الحرب مستمره
بكل الاحوال حتى تحقيق الاهداف هل من
مؤشرات
هنا نعم تحياتي صباح الخير يعني بطبيعه
الحال هنا يجب ان ناخذ هذا المضمار في
الكثير من النواحي في نهايه المطاف هو ليس
بالهاتف الاول
وفي كذلك هو تراكمي اصلا في مشهد مثير
للاهتمام اول رئيس امريكي لا يوجد لديه اي
سلطه فعليه او حتى محاوله لتصدير وكانه
يسيطر على الامور او كل الامور موجوده في
داخل سيطره معينه كهذه او كا اخرى حتى من
قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي تحديدا وهذه
الاشكاليه الكبرى باعتقادي في كل ما يجري
في داخل هذه الامور يعني في كثير من الرات
عندما كان يسال يسال بايدن حول ما اذا كان
سوف
اسرائيل تلتزم او لا تلتزم نتنياهو يلتزم
او لا يلتزم كان يجيب بكلمات ثلاثه اي هوب
سو انا امل ذلك فواضح جدا ان هذه احد اهم
الامور ومجريات الامور ما بين الطرفين كنا
قد اشرنا ان في نهايه المطاف هنالك معركه
حقيقيه ما بين الادارتين ما بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب معركه لديها مال انتخابيه لديها
مال لانقلاب في الحكم او تغيير الحكم بشكل
اضق ما بينكل كل منهما عملل في ان الحكم
سوف يتغير في الدوله الاخرى وبالتالي ياتي
اداره اكثر توافقا واكثر مناوه للسياسات
وباعتقاد حتى تلك المرحله حتى الانتخابات
الاولى التي سوف تكون ان كانت في واشنطن
او ان كانت في تل ابيب الامور سوف تكون
مبهمه فيها الكثير من البلبله وبطبيعه
الحال نتنياهو سوف يحاول ان يجر واشنطن في
الرمال المتحركه في داخل ارض طيب ماذا عن
ما اصدرته الرقابه الع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من تعليمات بشان التغطيه
الاعلاميه يعني الهدف هنا هل هو التعتيم
ام امر
اخر يعني بدايه بعيدا عن التعتيم يعني هنا
يجب ان نشير ان عاده يعني الاعلام
الاسرائيلي يتجند بكامله طواعيه اصلا في
مثل هذه الظروف لكي يكون يعني اداه
يستعملها الناطق العسكري بمفهوم كذا او
كاخر وهذا بالمناسبه ما كان في الاسابيع
الاولى لكن في نهايه المطاف هذه المعادله
تغيرت ربما ها ارتس غيرها ويدعو احرنوت
يعني المتواجدات في ما بين المركز
واليسار وفي معايير معينه هذا الامر احرج
هذه الحرب واحرج هذا الكابينت في ادارته
لكل هذه المحاوره يعني نحن نرى انه يتطرق
لامرين اثنين الامر الاول يتطرق الى مساله
الاسرى وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا وحساسه جدا حتى
يمكن القول في كل ما يخص الشارع
الاسرائيلي هنالك من يقول بان مثل مثل هذه
ال يعني المعلومات ومثل هذه الافلام ومثل
هذه الشرائط التي تبث في نهايه المطاف
ممكن ان تؤثر كثيرا على الشارع الاسرائيلي
وتقوم بمردود عكسي اي بكلمات اخرى ان في
في غرار المفاوضات يكون هنالك ثمن اكبر
واغلى للاسرى وهذا ما لا تريده اسرائيل
ولهذا السبب مثل هذه الامور وبثها وتحريض
الشارع تحديدا في هذه الجدليه هو امر لا
يبت في مصلحه اسرائيل هذا الامر الاول
والامر الثاني بنها نحن نتحدث عن زيارات
وكل ما يقوم به الجانب السياسي والعسكري
من النشاطات في داخل القطاع يعني هذا كذلك
يعني لا اظن ان هنالك اي جديد في في ذلك
ربما هو مجرد ابهام اضافته الى المساله
الرئيسيه وباعتقاد هي كل ما يخص الاسرى
تحديدا ا دعني انوه لهذا الخبر العاجل
بحسب مراسل الجزيره شهيده اذا وعدد من
الجرحى اثر قصف اس اسرائيليه الان في مخيم
البريج وسط قطاع غزه اذا بحسب مراسلنا
شهيده وعدد من الجرحى اثر قصف اسرائيلي في
مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه اعود اليك سيد
ايهاب ربما في سؤال اخير لا تزال هناك
اتهامات للحكومه الاسرائيليه بانها لا
تقدم اي مبادره لتحرير الاسرى حتى الان
بتقييمك كيف يتم يعني اداره هذا الملف
تحديدا من قبل حكومه نتنياهو في ظل
تصريحات متواصله من قبل اسرى كانوا
محتجزين وتم تحريرهم تصريحات ربما لصالح
المقاومه ومعاملتهم للاسرى ولا تخدم ابدا
الحكومه يعني صحيح جدا احد اهم الامور
باعتقادي كذلك التي يجب ان تضاف بكل ما
يخص التعتيم الاعلامي هو تصريحات مثل
تصريحات خان جولدشتاين في نهايه المطاف
يجب ان نتذكر ان احد اهم الامور التي
اشترطتها الشراك والاجهزه الامنيه عندما
تم تحرير هؤلاء الاسر بان لا يبثوا باي
كلمه الى داخل الاعلام لام والى الاعلام
تحديدا هؤلاء الاسر طبعا في نطاق معين
واضح جدا الامر خرجت عن خرجت عن
السيطره هذه الاشكاليه هنك الكثير من
النقض والانتقاص لاداره نتنياهو تحديدا
وحكومه نتنياهو في هذا الملف والكبيني هنا
يجب ان نتذكر بعيدا يعني لو اخذنا على
محمل الجد بان نتنياهو حقا يريد ان يتقدم
في هذا الملف ويريد ان ينهي هذا الملف ملف
الاسر رغم انه هو الوحيد الذي يبت الحياه
لهذه الحرب تحديدا ل الجانب الاسرائيلي
والذري الاولى التي يعتمد عليها لكن لو
فرضنا ان نتنياهو يريد ان يتقدم قدما في
هذا الملف يجب ان نتذكر انه كان لديه
الكثير من الانتقاص والانتقاد في مج في
نقطتين اثنتين الاولى في كتبه هو تحديدا
كان قد ذكر على سبيل المثال ان مثل هذه
الت صفقات التبادل هي صفقات تمس بامن
اسرائيل انتقاض كان لصفقه احمد جبريل على
سبيل المثال رغم انه جلعاد شليت هو
نعميت تم تحرير يحيى السنوار وبالتالي
اليمين ينتقص منه هذه الجزئيه الان هنالك
اثمان لاسامي قد تكلف اسرائيل غاليا مثل
عبد الله البرغوثي ومروان البرغوثي وهذا
الامر الذي يخشاه تحديدا نتنياهو كذلك
امام اليمين مره اخرى شكرا لك ايهاب
جبارين الكاتب المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
كنت معنا من حيفا